build subdivisions
move to Dallas I won't have them here
that's right nothing happens in this
Valley I don't know about
called progress John
progress doesn't need your permission
yeah this Valley it does
the hit series Yellowstone has ignited
interest in all things Western and that
includes the sport of cutting where a
Horse and Rider work together to handle
cattle now cutting is skyrocketing in
popularity as viewers want a piece of
the action for themselves Janet shamlian
has the story
my head here
the hit series Yellowstone is full of
action-packed scenes like this
[Music]
[Applause]
A Horse and Rider head to head with a
calf in a back and forth test of will
this is the hold on for dear life sport
of cutting
things like this on television's most
watched show have given cutting
visibility it's never had then
do not need
[Music]
wow
that's a nice horse the thrill of a ride
many now want to try themselves it feels
like you're strapped on a turbo with a
vacuum uh like a missile
Lindy Burch would know
a world champion and among the sports
most decorated thank you Linda we met
her at a competition in Fort Worth
Yellowstone has exposed
a whole new group of people to cutting
what's that been like it's like the
phone started ringing about what you
know where can I get lessons and I want
to ride a cutting horse the increase has
been phenomenal
and that's at The Cutting world on fire
we call it the Yellowstone effect but
the last year and a half two years the
prices have have dramatically increased
Jeremy Barwick is a Wheeler Dealer in
the sport so this is third Edge
he is the current ncha open horse of the
Year Barwick owns this Texas breeding
for facility as well as an auction
company selling the world's top mares
and stallions and I wouldn't want people
to think it's only for the very wealthy
because it's not I've seen people buy
horses for four and five thousand
dollars they go and win hundreds of
thousands of dollars welcome to my
playground
this is Dylan
excellent now you're ready to go Lindy
Burke says anyone can learn just like me
back up straight and then you're going
to turn him right over his Hawks
very good there you go and H is no
barrier we have nine-year-olds in the
open competing in the open and we have
85 year olds competing in the open
because the great equalizer is your
horse come competitors have two and a
half minutes the writer is in charge
while isolating a cow then the horse
Takes Over
highly trained the best have agility and
style how important is the connection
between Horse and Rider well to me it's
tantamount
of Yellowstone's Cowboys like actor
Corey J Smith are real life cutters
drawing larger than ever crowds to
celebrity competitions yeah
requiring strategy precision and a darn
good horse and it's great for two and a
half minutes it's it's the greatest ride
you're ever going to have that's it a
sport rooted in Western culture of the
past gets a moment in the present for
CBS Saturday I'm Janet shamley in Fort
Worth
[Applause]
it's really amazing to watch it is it's
very cool I was trying to think of what
to compare it to but there's something
very cool about watching the mirroring
that they're doing while keeping that
cattle no I'm so glad she interviewed
Lindy Burch she is a Phenom a Pioneer in
Rodeo and certainly as national
champions of of cutting it's just it's
it's so good this you're still right and
Janet did a nice job yes there you go